- But I actually heard we
have something in common.
So I have a really embarrassing story,
well actually it's online you can see it
of how I mess Meryl Streep.
So embarrassing because I wasn't prepared.
I feel like one's soul should be prepared
when you turn around and
Meryl-frickin'-Streep
is standing there.
- Yeah, yeah, you want to be, yeah.
- Universe middle finger to you.
(Keegan laughs)
Because I acted like a fool.
But I actually hear you have
a funny story about Meryl.
- Oh, I acted, first for me too.
If you're not prepared.
- Maybe it's here fault
she does this.
- I think it's Meryl.
- Meryl does this.
- How dare she be that good.
How dare you scare everybody like that.
How dare you have a work
ethic and all the talent,
that's not fair.
- It's rude.
- I was leaving a charity event
and I was going, I was performing
and so I was running out
some hotel in New York City.
I was like, I gotta get to the theater,
I gotta get to the theater!
And I'm running from this event
and I'm running down the hall,
like booking, I was like power walking.
(audience laughs)
Just down the hall.
- Like the older ladies in the mall.
- Exactly, it's like I got
there, I gotta get to the stores.
And up the escalator comes this vision.
It's Meryl Streep.
(both angelic singing)
And I'm walking and in mid-stride,
so just turn like this a little bit Kelly.
So mid-stride I just go
oh, oh, oh, I'm sorry!
(Kelly laughs)
I'm sorry I just grabbed.
I am sorry, I just grabbed you.
I apologize, you are my
favorite person in the world.
- [Kelly] Oh my god.
- And then I'm like walking
forward after I did that.
And she walks past and
she just turns around
and very sweetly goes, "You're
one of my favorite people
"in the world."
(audience sighs)
Which is exactly what you
would expect from Meryl Streep.
It's exactly what you would
expect from Meryl Streep.
- She's perfection.
She may have caressed my cheek it's fine.